you're in a lot of trouble of course he
is you want from me that's what loki
does
oh dave and you need the goddess
oh that looks cool so it's unpredictable
oh yeah they got
[Applause]
welcome back to new rockstars the clock
is indeed
ticking as loki episode 1 is mere days
away
and this latest promo footage gives us a
clearer sense
of how powerful exactly the tva agents
are
compared to the god of mischief but what
exactly are these
agents or as we are gonna ask this
episode at least
what the clock clock we're trying out
we're trying out new things every week
and then we'll ask you guys which one
you watch i dig what the clock though i
dig it
i like what the clock uh and i'll get my
own wilson impression
and other waves on the show that's not
even a good one i got it yo your
working pressure is pretty good it's
pretty impressive i guess i can do it
certain
certain sentences other ones not so much
hey this is inside marvel i'm eric boss
i'm here with mt how you feeling empty
i'm feeling good i like a good loki like
trailer
tv spot whatever so like this chaos spot
is pretty great i love it
it's a good one yeah uh so yeah we're
counting down the days to loki with
weekly episodes looking ahead to really
all the marvel phase four titles and
this week in addition to talking about
new things we're hearing about loki
we're going to talk about loki's
possible crossover
with the other big piece of mcu news we
got this week the eternals
and also this episode we're going to
talk about a quote we got from
loki showrunner mike waldron about how
he wants to try to connect to other mcu
titles we're also going to talk about
aaron taylor johnson because that's some
big marvel news if you want to address
massive news oh yeah uh so a reminder to
check out newrockstarsmerch.com for
all of our great merch options we got
shirts like this one we got hoodies
jackets water bottles whatever you need
new rockstarsmerch.com we got a new loki
design in the works
hopefully we'll be able to announce it
next week but mt what's our first
question this week
well um our first what the clock of the
day is what the clock exactly
are the agents of the tva and what type
of life forms are they
yeah how powerful are these things
because they seem pretty powerful
because they decked loki in the face
oh man uh well in marvel comics uh and
you can fact check me on this nt the the
tva is just mostly depicted as this vast
bureaucratic
agency these rules everyone kind of just
has to follow
uh they have a seemingly endless number
of chrono monitors each one for each
timeline they got an infinite army of
minutemen is the name of their cops they
just arrest and detain any violators
they got this hierarchy of judges
that decide these cases and enforce them
but i don't know i don't think you often
see these god
level characters waging war against the
tva
or like loki says in the show to burn
this place to the ground
yeah yeah they mostly are just like they
use the fear of the rule of law
to enforce their power as opposed to any
kind of physical
might or magical ability yeah i don't
really there's not really a lot of
instances where like you know gods like
loki or anybody really
interact with the tv8 the tv are really
like this really authoritative
authority like the a in the tva is very
strong so like yeah because they exist
outside of time and space it's like we
have like a bigger jurisdiction than
most other beings that reside inside of
the marvel universe so
yeah yeah they aren't any particular
known species
they're really just like cogs of the
universe performing a very specific
function just to keep everything running
on time and to make sure no rules are
broken
so yeah the power isn't in their bodies
it's really in the agency they serve
but it seems like marvel studios is
doing something a bit different
in this loki footage there is a ton of
fighting and conflict and
fists swung at each other's faces
decked loki 100 nasty hook there
yeah like i got i replayed that like as
many times as i could because it's so
satisfying it's so
satisfying it's great to see uh and like
yeah we all see in this trailer loki
getting like ricocheted around the tva
viewing room
uh we all see other characters like
sophia demartino's character
maybe lady loki sparring with tva guards
and then yeah they use these staff-like
weapons that
painfully erase people from existence
yeah kind of disintegrating them
yes um i think that this could actually
be like a miniaturized version of the uh
the red cannon the retcon cannon of the
tba
which they use to erase people from from
timelines so like it's so
cool to see that visual yeah it's just
now this handheld weapon that's pretty
cool
uh and it's pretty visceral like his
scream
that scared the [ __ ] out of loki uh but
what's different in the i mean when
you're comparing this to the comics the
comics have it's it's a
weird quirky world where uh things are
just introduced for the stakes of a
story whereas when you're
bringing in the cinematic universe
things all kind of have to cohabitate
you know so uh and mike waldron even
says like the tva
is probably going to connect to other
things in future marvel
so we have to get a sense of what the
the
power balance is when it comes to the
tva and the fact that they're able to
arrest
loki who is a super powerful sorcerer he
possesses an infinity stone when they
get them
that tells us that this group must be
among the most powerful beings in the
marvel cinematic universe
oh yeah they gotta yeah and it makes me
think empty that their power
might be derived from something beyond
from some kind of cosmic level
yeah like they're telling us the time
keepers but i'm thinking it might come
from someone
on the celestial or cosmic level maybe
someone like kronos
who's the master of time and i think
kronos is an interesting name to look at
because
he's related to thanos he's thanos
grandfather he's a lars
father he's also zuris's father and
zerus was
thena's father zina and thanos are first
cousins
movie where this whole family tree could
get explored
oh yeah for sure like we're definitely
going to see that their family
um the family tree of thanos explored in
the eternals and like we even got
um a large mentioned in avengers
infinity war
yes infinity war yes not end game
absolutely so like yeah they're
definitely teasing
that line and so if we got a lars in the
mcu already
kronos has got to be uh somewhere so
yeah i do like that kronos connection
there
and one thing i've started to explore
more and more mt is this idea that
the celestials may have been okay
with what thanos did or what he was
trying to do to snap
all of a half of all life out of
existence we know that the celestials
had this
uh history with the infinity stones
issan or essen
this we were talking before the show we
don't know if it's issan or s and
uh whoever that celestial was in the
collector's story in guardians of the
galaxy had the power stone
um and nebula said in endgame that
the soul stone was at the center of
celestial existence
uh and i think there's this connection
there they may have sent thanos on this
mission to do this
yeah um and that could uh and maybe
that's
their gripe now with the eternals right
is like the eternals have been
sponsoring the avengers if they love
captain america so much
and captain america and iron man all
their friends are the ones who stopped
thanos's mission
uh and the tva noticed they arrest loki
they're more upset with like people
screwing up with the timeline
why didn't they arrest thanos at any
point you know for
his stealing of the time stone um
that must mean that according to tva
what thanos did
was the correct path was the rightful
future
so that tells us they are at least uh
neutral no opinion or totally okay with
what thanos did
uh because it was just what time was
supposed to be
and now they're getting mad at people
who meddled with that timeline to them
that's a bigger violation
than thanos committing like a gen then
thanos committing genocide on a cosmic
scale
uh so i just find it interesting that
they could be linked to this higher
power
that would be okay with what thanos did
and now the big conflict that the
avengers of earth are facing maybe the
eternals of earth are facing
uh is going to be with groups like the
tva and other cosmic universal
authorities
who actually kind of wanted thanos to
carry that out i mean yeah like the the
the common thread between the tva and
thanos like you were alluding to earlier
is that
they sort of were acting like uh
universal custodians in a way you know
because like thanos was trying to make
sure that like
all life in the universe could continue
and so the tva wants to make sure
that all time in the universe can
continue so like you know the tva could
very much be down with what thanos was
doing because
what if this is not the first time that
a thanos type figure
has been running you know when he got
running maintenance on the universe you
know what i'm saying
right so like you know it could just be
like oh man like thanos is
completely fine you know until you know
i feel like the tva would not be cool
thanos
until he uh destroyed all the stones
because now the stones are outside of
the timeline
so yeah if you're if we're comparing
this all to the sci-fi of authors like
douglas adams right like in the 70s when
a lot of these comics are being written
like they were totally inspired by
hitchhiker's guide and a lot of sci-fi
like that uh
a common theme in that kind of uh you
know sci-fi humor
is that earth is just a small part of
the universe and the interest of earth
is often completely in conflict with the
interests of
other larger bodies right and the way
that you know hitchhiker's guide begins
with earth being
uh paved away for uh
interstellar super highway that's kind
of like what the tva
probably sees as well they don't care
about earth
uh galactus obviously doesn't care about
uh the people of any one planet he feeds
off of planets you know
silver surfer is kind of co-opted into
that so
what we're going to start to see as the
mcu starts to go more cosmic
that's the front of the war that we're
gonna be fighting on are
uh the avengers and people who are loyal
to earth uh fighting against these
cosmic forces who are indifferent
and uh to me i lump in the tva with
those cosmic forces
oh yeah you gotta i mean like in like i
love that type of perspective
because like because we're human beings
on earth we're just like yeah earth is
like the most important thing in the
world but like
it's just a small speck in a massive
massive universe
and like we cannot and like the people
of mcu earth cannot comprehend the
overall
you know goals of these cosmic beings so
like you know we're sort of messing
things up with like the events of end
game and everything and like you know
messing with the tesseract and like
messing with all these infinity stones
so you know they're i'm sure the
celestials of the tva cannot stand
mcu earth it's like what is going on
here why are these people so weird
right um so we're going to talk more
about the tva
and about other big marvel news first we
want to thank some people who helped us
make this episode
uh starting with our friends at credit
karma money uh we all like instant
gratification with credit karma money
you could win
cash reimbursements for debit purchases
uh credit karma money is a brand new
checking account where you can win
cash reimbursements for making purchases
when you use your credit karma money
debit card you can win daily instant
karma purchase reimbursements on items
up to
five thousand dollars just pay with your
debit card and if you win
you'll be notified on the spot and your
instant karma cash will be added
back to your spend account credit karma
money has already given away over 3
million
on instant karma to over 50 000 credit
karma members
open your fdic insured spend account for
free there's no minimum balance
requirements no overdraft fees and free
withdrawals from a network of over 50
000 atms right now visit creditkarma.com
win money to open your free account and
start winning instant karma
go to creditkarma.com to sign up for the
free account start winning instant karma
that's credit card.com
win money insta karma is sponsored by
credit card no purchase necessary
exclusions and terms applied c rules
banking services provided by mvp bank
inc member fdic
maximum balance and transfer limits
apply we also want to thank mint mobile
for sponsoring this episode
after years of fine print contracts and
getting ripped off by big wireless
providers we've learned that
there's always a catch that's what sets
mint mobile apart they are noticeably
catch-free met mobile's secret sauce is
that they're the first company to sell
wireless service online only
so by cutting out retail stores there's
no crazy overhead costs that get passed
down to you in the form of mystery fees
instead mint just passes on those sweet
savings directly to you
here at new rockstars philip switched to
mint mobile service he's loved it
he uses the same phone and saves a bunch
of money every month he's stuffing all
that saved money into
his mattress and he says he's never
slept better mobile offers premium
wireless for just
15 bucks a month all plans come with
unlimited talk and text
plus high-speed data delivered on the
nation's largest 5g network
and if you're not 100 satisfied mint
mobile has you covered with their
seven-day money-back guarantee
to get your new wireless plan for just
15 bucks a month and to get the plan
shipped to your door for free go to
mintmobile.com
marvel that's mintmobile.com marvel cut
your wireless bill to 15 bucks a month
at memmobile.com marvel we also want to
thank bluetooth for sponsoring this
episode our friends at blue chew have a
unique online service that delivers the
same active ingredients as viagra and
cialis but chewable form and at a
fraction of the cost bluetooth is an
online prescription service so no
doctor's office or pharmacy trips it
ships right to your door in a discrete
package
you sign up at bluetooth.com consult
with one of your licensed medical
providers and once you're approved you
receive your prescription within days
there licensed medical providers work
with you to find the right ingredient
and strength
and blue chew is chewable just like it
says in the name which is great news for
folks that don't like swallowing pills
so
if you could benefit from extra
confidence when it's time to perform
visit bluetooth.com for more details and
important safety information
and we've got a special deal for our
audience try bluetooth free when you use
the promo code inside marvel at check
out just pay the five dollars in
shipping
that's bluechew.com promo code marvel to
receive your first month free and we
thank bluetooth for sponsoring this show
all right so back to loki um yeah there
was this interesting line in the promo
mt
where uh mobius zimbobius told loki like
you've brought chaos to
our timeline which is just interesting
because the tva is supposed to oversee
all these different timelines
so what is this what timeline are they
attached to does that mean he
is specifically attached to this
timeline or is that is there like a
prime timeline
in the way that the marvel studios is
doing it ah that's a good question i
think that there is like a a
prime timeline and like the timeline for
the main universe is set in is is the
main timeline like
and so the timeline that we're in loki
that he branches off to
he sort of makes his own timeline and i
think that from what we learn
in avengers end game with uh the ancient
one i think that when
you know a timeline gets branched off
that timeline is basically sort of
doomed
because there aren't um like all six
infinity stones
inside of that timeline so yeah i'm not
sure if the tv
especially cares about if you know
branch timelines sort of get all wrong
because like
it's that main timeline they're trying
to preserve so like maybe that
chaos on that you know purple planet is
a timeline just
just going to [ __ ] because there isn't
all six infinity stones in it but
who knows i like that idea a lot uh or
that maybe there are
two tesseracts in that or two space
stones in that universe and it causes
the rules of uh spatial relationships
between planets and heavenly bodies
to break down and fall apart and moons
crashed into their surfaces
of the planets of being the satellite of
um
like and it's so weird in the in this
promo footage that after
loki gets booked and he's in his
detainee jumpsuit you still see him
holding that tesseract which like
what does that mean they don't want the
tesseract to be destroyed or they don't
want the space stone to be destroyed did
they remove the space stone from the
tesseract it's like
there's a lot of mystery of who built
that tesseract around the space stone
exactly because the tesseract was
understood to be something different
before
you know people knew that there was an
infinity stone in it yeah
like i what what is the purpose of the
actual tesseract
um container like i've always wanted to
learn like what is going on and what is
that
that weird glow inside of the tesseract
box that surrounds the actual space
infinity stone like what these questions
need to be answered because like
yeah can the tesseract open portals
without the space stone i think the
implication is no it need only the space
stone can
have those kind of bifurcations to them
you know yeah and like you know that's
what the whole deal with uh project
pegasus is i think that you know a lot
of
that you know that weird goo inside of
the weird like sludge or whatever it is
inside of the tesseract is dark energy
like because like that's what uh the pe
uh project pegasus is uh really messing
around with
so um you know we could we could learn
like hey this is a box that contains
dark energy which
you know it kind of contains the power
of the souls of the space stone i don't
know but like you know
project pegasus definitely saw the value
in in uh we're
trying to break down the the tesseract
anyway yeah uh i think so
um yeah it's early in mc phase one i
think they didn't they called it the
tesseract but
it was really based on the cosmic cube
um which is a different thing
uh and it wasn't until what do we want
to say around
uh guardians of the galaxy i think it
started with thor the dark world
was the first one to introduce the idea
of infinity stones which even if you go
back and re-watch that movie
uh clearly they brought in anthony
hopkins uh
in adr after the fact to mention the
idea of an infinity stone and i think
it's because they were working on
um age of ultron at that point um
like they started to write age of ultron
while thor the dark world was in
post-production so i guess
somewhere in there kevin feige was
talking with joss whedon uh
and they're like let's start laying the
seeds for this in some of these movies
uh and at that point they made the
tesseract uh the
container of the space stone maybe that
seems like a really
rational like logical way of how things
could have gone so
but it was done the point is it was done
after the fact you know
like they didn't plan all this out ahead
of time it was kind of like we'll just
make as many marvel movies as people
will be willing to go see
and then once it was super popular
they're like oh let's kind of retcon
some of this stuff to make it all fine
see like that does make sense but like i
don't know man i just feel like kevin
feige has really been
like he's had like an idea of like all
this stuff
since like probably as early as like uh
avengers one
maybe like i think he's had i think he's
had a a broad vision
and the guy's been a genius i'm not
saying this to knock him at all oh yes
it's just i don't think he's had a
perfect vision of everything because
otherwise they wouldn't have made the
stones the color they made them
they would have just matched it with the
color from the comics they would have
put thanos's gauntlet in odin's vault
uh because you could see them make these
little jokes afterwards were held
interested over saying thank you this is
like
there are all these little details where
i mean there was even like mephisto
in uh in the paperwork that nick fury
gave cap
uh in the first avengers movie so
clearly whedon and his
uh prop team was like oh we're gonna do
the infinity gauntlet storyline with
mephisto
you know who is that i think there's
actually also like a sword reference
within uh that agent carter
one shot um when she opens up the
drawers like it's sword to shield and
all that stuff like
sword has it been around for that long
wait time i think selvage mentions
sword uh at the end of thor he's talking
about uh
shield and sword i think uh okay so you
have to listen closely
or it's maybe in the captions okay so
like was
has sword really just been in the
universe all this time and i just didn't
know
i think that's the idea of it yeah
impossible i know everything eric i just
don't know
but like yeah no i totally understand
like i think um i remember
watching like or reading an interview or
something with james gunn saying that
like they changed the color of
um the power stone mid
uh production of guardians of the game
it's gonna be red
so yeah so like you know you're right
like things sort of just like
you know they're freaking things out on
the way sort of right yeah
yeah for sure um now let's talk about
eternals right do you think loki could
cameo in eternals because the eternals
had that um
that volcano eruption and a lot of
people were like whoa is that mount
vesuvius that we saw in the background
of the loki footage
uh i'm not so sure about that but what
do you think empty
um i think that it'd be a great way for
you know to connect the eternals to the
broader mcu and like you know
they are going across time the long way
and like loki's popping through time so
like
i think that that's highly possible you
know we might even see eternals in loki
as like a little primer for for what's
to come because like that's what these
marvel shows sort of do it's like hey
you know we're sort of like you know a
nice little spice to the
you know the movie mcu um so yeah i
think that there's
some crossover potential there but what
do you think what you got potential for
sure here's the deal i want loki to
cameo in everything
and part of me still thinks that that
dude in the background who kind of
looked like tom hiddleston
in avengers end game when they're in the
70s at camp lehigh there's some dudes
sitting on a bench
and i i know i pointed that in a video
before like was that loki in the 70s
yeah i don't i just think the shape of
that volcano in uh
and the eternals trailer just looks
different than the shape of the volcano
uh we don't really know fully what
vesuvius looked like that was 79 a.d
but in the looking footage they used
footage from mount st helens which had a
kind of a flatter shape to it whereas
this is a bit more pointed
uh and i i think it's more likely that
that's some
you know civilization the eternals
failed to protect or failed to save and
i would i'm hoping that ends up being
atlantis and the volcano erupts
oh my god the landmass to break off and
then sink into the ocean
oh my god something yeah like that'd be
like a really great way to like tease
namor because like yeah we're gonna get
neymar very soon he's gotta come i hope
so um
and like it's oh they gotta cast uh
what's his name glenn from the walking
dead
yeah yeah steven would be great he'd be
great that guy needs to get in the mcu
cast him oh for sure he's going to be in
the mcu eventually like he's just too
he's too great of an actor
really nice guy he used to uh perform at
the improv theater i used to perform
that he'd always have a huge
huge crowd it would be fun because he
would play in one of the back theaters
uh and uh he could play on any stage he
wanted but he just had a friend who
hosted a show one of the back theaters
and those were the tiny stages me and my
indie teams would uh put up shows
and be like normally you have like 12
people in the audience it's just you
and the other teams that are performing
just watching you that's it
yeah but there'd be one i had like a 10
30 show and then i would see like
50 people come out of the theater from
the show before and i'd be like
what the hell is going on and these are
people you never see it at
the theater before all younger folks
yeah and then the last one to come out
would be oh steven yen
that's why that's why there are 50
people crammed in there
because you're just between your hands
power you know it's it's just the it's
that you
magnetism you know yeah
yeah uh now actually i should read this
quote exactly from mike waldron he did
an interview
uh i think it's a total film and he said
quote all of these stories in their own
way are interconnected and have
ramifications i think that certainly our
aim with the loki series was for it to
have wide reaching ramifications across
the mcu moving forward so you know was i
having to clean up some of the messes
that i made with loki
maybe so uh so yeah there you go i think
that's uh
if he said he was just trying to tell
his own story as most of these other
people do like when he asks the show
writers of one division falcon winner
soldier
he's saying no no i want to connect to
as many things as i possibly can
uh which gets me really excited for this
show which our next question kind of
addresses that okay so our next what the
clock of the day
is in this trailer loki says a bit of
both something that wanda chirps
in episode three of one division of
course so could loki join wanda in
spreading chaos
in the multiverse of madness eric yeah i
hope so right like that seems like the
perfect
place for loki to pop up i mean both
titles loki
and multiverse of madness are dealing
with like the fragility of reality
right and how you screw with the the
rules of the universe
chaos is gonna come from that and this
this term chaos coming up in this
trailer
it seems synonymous with multiverse of
madness right right
oh yeah absolutely and like you know
loki is
a god of chaos he's not the god of chaos
but like he's a god of mischief
and so like you know it'd be a great way
to you know like sort of
connect that the chaos that like you
know concept
that loki is sort of introducing to
these different realities to multiverse
madness like there is definitely some
sort of type of connection there
but like i don't know if loki will
end up connecting to multiverse of
madness
directly because like i think that there
may be a difference between
timelines branch timelines and like
actual
different universes different realities
because like yeah because like i think
that
you know one universe can have a zillion
different timelines and like
each universe might have their own tva i
don't know
but like i just think that you know all
of the timelines that we're going to see
in loki are
um contained into the one um marvel the
mcu that we know
um so i don't know but yeah there is a
definite connection there with with
chaos for sure right
and i'm with you i'm not uh certain this
means loki
obviously both them saying a bit of both
it doesn't mean that
he's got a cameo and i mean starland
said that too
yeah uh right yeah a lot of people say
that um but
uh i think just the nature of the
characters do lead themselves to be in
similar kind of stories for sure
uh i would say that when it comes to the
way
marvel studios is uh structuring their
multiverse
the fact that end game was all about
time and timelines
leads me to think that timelines are
gonna be the way
they just uh they distinguish one
reality from the other
um and that's only because that they
could have done anything
uh to do the logic of end game they
didn't have to make it a time travel
movie they could have
used magic of branch realities and i'm
just going to an alternate reality and
we're pulling it from there
uh they could have you know they
uh they didn't have to make it a
something that had to teach us something
about
quantum mechanics and uh the epr paradox
and stuff that was a choice and i think
that was deliberate by kevin feige
he told the writers of uh that movie i
want time travel to be part of this i
want
timelines to be an element of this movie
and they're like
uh okay all right cool and the reason we
bring up end games so much
is it's not only the most profitable
movie like ever
for marvel uh it's the fact that like
marvel is obsessed with endgame
marvel referenced in game in both of
their titles since then
it's all about the events of that movie
were so game changing
every marvel title since then has been
kind of obsessed with it
i assume black widow won't be but yeah
it seems like everything else will be
so yeah i think since that movie's about
timelines i think the
mcu going forward will be kind of about
timelines yeah i mean like they
that's the yeah you're totally right
that's the first movie that really
introduced the concept
of um you know branching timelines and
all that stuff so like you know
yeah i definitely for sure they and
marvel studios definitely sees the value
in end game
and we'll keep referencing ed gabe and
like the the ramifications of them game
moving forward i mean we got a
whole movie called quantum mania coming
out yeah like exactly
hardcore leading on end game so yeah for
sure
which is great uh well speaking of the
maximoff family let's talk about aaron
taylor johnson being cast as craven the
hunter by sony and it's gonna be a solo
film
um they announced it they announced that
it would be a solo film last year i
believe
uh it's kind of like what they're doing
with uh morbius living vampire
with venom and venom let there be
carnage uh it seems like these are all
other spider-man villain movies where
the
the villain is kind of the anti-hero of
the story and spider-man won't be in it
um and it looks like it'll be based on
the
storyline of craven's last hunt which is
an amazing
uh comic event that i highly recommend
you check out
really really delves into the character
of craven as this kind of tragic figure
very cool uh what are your thoughts on
this mt
i think that this is a huge piece of of
news because like i i think that this is
part of like something that i've
been thinking about ever since wanda
vision in something called the boner
effect
uh named after ralph boner and you know
because
people are like oh my god why isn't evan
peters playing
quicksilver like that was the big
question and i think that every universe
has the same
faces like the same actor faces but
sometimes they're in different roles and
so when i heard
that aaron taylor johnson is going to be
craving the hunter i was like oh my god
this makes sense because the face this
is the face of pietro or you know
for i should say hey taylor johnson in
another universe being portrayed as
craven so like this makes me feel that
you know
we're gonna see this craven within
whatever spider-verse
type sinister six is going on because
you know he probably has
his own you know dealings with maybe a
different version of spider-man like
what if there's like a spider-man that's
literally like insane is like murdering
people or whatever it's like i have to
hunt this guy
you know he's my biggest prey and so
like whenever you know whoever comes to
pick craven up to be part of the
sinister six he's like well in my
universe spider-man's insane
so like yeah i'll join you guys whatever
um so you know i just think this is like
the beginnings of like
multiverse shenanigans and like yeah
it's gonna be great but how do you feel
about this
um i'm okay with it i don't really have
an opinion either way
um i think a couple different camps of
people were
annoyed with this news you have the
group of folks who wanted craven to be
played by someone else like jason momoa
or something like that
but whenever i hear that i it annoys me
whenever people are cast in roles and
then everyone on twitter becomes a
casting director
it's like why don't you just trust
actors to act you know
like it's the same thing with heath
ledger when heath ledger was announced
for a dark knight everyone was like oh
pretty boy heath ledger is like
trust him to be an actor like you can
exactly
actors jobs are to emulate and to
change their bodies to change their
voices to change their
uh mannerisms to convey something
so suspend your disbelief don't just
attach a face
to a character forever um but the other
side of this is i think people are also
kind of
weirded out by sony taking a well-known
uh superhero face from the mcu and
but i think that also tells us that
marvel did not have plans to
bring back um aaron taylor johnson as
pietro
um so for those people who thought that
the reason they made evan peters just
ralph
boner uh and not the fox version of
quicksilver is because they had plans to
bring back aaron taylor johnson it
sounds like
neither of those are marvel's plan and
the question then becomes well then what
is marvel's plan because we should have
some version of quicksilver in the mcu
the version we should have the reason we
should have every uh marvel hero
in some form in the mcu i think
eventually we're looking at it ahead of
multiverse reset
i think sometime in the next three or
four years there's just gonna be some of
it
because all these actors contracts are
gonna run out you know chris hemsworth
isn't gonna be the only person playing
thor
forever uh and you're gonna start seeing
all these roles recast
and that way we'll have everyone be able
to come back any character that might
have been killed off you know
you can bring back other new people and
recast whoever you want and i think
that's gonna be their plan with all the
x-men uh with quicksilver with wolverine
yeah for sure i feel like the x-men you
know the the proper mcu x-men whenever
they show up
they're going to be new iterations but i
do feel like
we are going to get you know like you
said like some type of
event like maybe a secret wars or
something where we see you know
that you know our favorite quicksilver
from the fox universe where we see you
know
maybe the fantastic four with with chris
evans making an appearance
as part of the boner effect see i don't
think that's gonna happen
i don't think so no i i don't think
they're gonna bring in hugh jackman i
don't think they're going to bring in
ian mckellen the fact they brought in
evan peters i don't think they
brought i think once evan peters was
revealed as ralph boner
uh that kind of put the nail in the
coffin to those theories
because other than ryan reynolds coming
over as deadpool
what other actors is marvel interested
in bringing back
and those actors are also interested in
coming back hugh jackman's done i don't
think he wants to play
well like i don't think that you know if
if they do like bring in like past
actors i don't think it's going to be
for the long haul i think it's probably
going to be for like this
celebratory like this is marvel like
secret wars type
movie where it says like this is one
contained event and then you know
they're gone forever and now we're
moving forward
see i don't think they're gonna do that
because that one event
is gonna be huge and i think they'd be
worried rightfully so that it would
confuse
fans minds that so then who is wolverine
in this universe i
paid money to see this guy right now as
wolverine
so it's going to make it more confusing
if in the next movie they're like just
kidding here's a wolverine
i think marvel's going to invest its
money in whatever their new
uh people are also this is a financial
consideration
those actors even for a cameo is going
to be expensive as hell
it's true you can save so much more
money by just casting actors who have
not been in a ton of stuff
but are still super talented and giving
them a chance to play these roles
i think that's gonna be their way
forward i don't think they're gonna
they're gonna dust off uh you know hugh
jackman ian mckellen oh man
it would be i feel like the seek i i
really
feel like a secret wars type deal is
coming we're like and i agree i think a
secret wars type deal is coming too but
it's gonna be with new actors playing
these characters i don't think it's
gonna be with the old actors it's just
not how hollywood works
okay i mean like that's very logical
though that's very logical so like
that's probably
you know a very likely route that
they'll take but like
man i just feel like there's there's a
lot of money to be made within
this huge multiverse clash thing but i
don't know
i mean it's the same way like uh i mean
they're not recasting wesley snipes his
blade they're bringing him hershel ali
there are bigger names right now you can
get to play these roles
just as much you know i think if you if
you try to get
uh you know whoever your dream cast is
from the past um installments getting
chris evans to play
they'd rather have chris evans play
captain america in some other form
they're not going to get him to play
johnny storm they're going to want their
new johnny storm
whoever this is true um but i mean
that's just my thinking on it whatever
i've been
wrong before without oh no like it's
very logical and me
i'm just thinking like with my like you
know bright eyes like oh my gosh it'd be
great to see everything everybody that i
love again but like
me too i mean i'd love to see who jack
may come back i just
don't think it's gonna happen oh yeah
but uh i do
think that one thing when it comes to
this aaron taylor johnson news
sony's got to figure out their version
of a live-action spider-man
uh and i don't think they can either
it's a contractual thing or a financial
thing they can't get tom holland in
there
to play peter parker in the movie
because it becomes a spider-man movie
but it doesn't make sense for all these
characters to just be in their own
worlds
without spider-man in it because all of
their existence are directly tied
to spider-man it was weird in the first
venom movie to
have this venom story without spider-man
in it i think it's gonna be weird and
venom let there be carnage
i think it's gonna be super weird and
morbius and it seems like they're kind
of walking this line of having like
spider-man sightings but peter parker's
not gonna be in it
so like bring in miles morales like
do something to have a spider-man in the
story
um and you know like i like your idea
empty of having the spider-man be the
villain of that universe you know
but i think audiences are gonna reject
it after a while of like why am i
watching this story
i mean yeah but like something that just
popped into my brain
when you were talking is that like what
if the reason why there are no
spider-man's in you know
venom's universe or like potentially you
know craven's universe
is that morlen and the inheritors are i
killed them before
like you know their stories even began
like what if like this is part of the
the spider-verse narrative it's like
there is no spider-man because he's dead
like he was yeah i would want that uh i
would love that
that would be a great one that's the
reason behind it um i think
the hard part i think for a lot of fans
is we love the version
of spider-man that we have right now
with tom holland oh yeah uh
and like tom holland is not gonna be
playing this part forever but
let's be honest the reason they have
this sharing deal with uh marvel is
because
kevin feige's uh guidance in it has been
a big reason why this character's
successful the fact that spider-man
could show up in civil war in infinity
war and in-game like
it's this sense of a promise that just
around the corner from him
are the avengers uh and the avengers are
connected with this story i think you
need that i think you need for him to be
the friendly neighborhood spider-man he
needs to be part of a friendly
neighborhood
and if sony can't deliver that uh
then i i think a lot of fans aren't
excited about a future where only
sony is doing spider-man stories like
but at the end of the day is sony ever
going to sell the rights of these marvel
characters back to disney
sony would have to be in dire financial
straits to
do that and right now they have uh
plenty of ways to make money
aside from hollywood they can buffer a
bad year
of of movie releases with selling more
playstations
to who i got one i get so hard to get a
ps5
dude it's so annoying oh god but like
yeah i know for sure like i feel like
sony's not really willing to sell
spiderman because he's a cash cow in
more than one way
so much money so much profit share that
they get with disney
because disney's taking a bigger chunk
of it sony still can bankroll
all their other investments in terms of
film production budgets
with just the money they make from these
spider-man movies even venom without
spider-man in it made a [ __ ] ton of
money for them
yeah like those spider-man related
characters like spider-man's like whole
like story since like he started he's
there's so many interesting characters
in his universe that like sony you know
struggles
with making um you know pro like you
know individual properties for outside
of the marvel universe in my opinion
anyway
yeah so you know yeah it's just really
frustrating
but yeah whatever we'll take we get a
i'm excited for aaron taylor johnson
this guy's a great actor i think he's to
act the hell out of it this is great
casting this is fantastic
it's really good in this role he's going
to kick ass it's going to be so
definitely makes me more excited for
this movie than i was before um
because aaron taylor johnson's great and
uh and i'm excited to see what marvel
eventually does
for the x-men and quicksilver um i think
they're looking forward not looking to
the past and maybe that's for the best
um but uh let us know your comments down
below i'm sure you will either way
um it's okay to disagree with us just
try to be respectful
to each other be nice to everybody it's
okay to disagree just be like hey guys
this is why i don't
agree that's okay yeah that's filling
the dialogue neither of us are saying
the studios have to do one thing or
another we don't own
these characters right
yeah but in the meantime we're not going
to gatekeep and say that the studios
have to do one thing over another right
that's not our that's not that's not our
style that's not what we do
but uh thank you for joining us for this
episode of inside marvel we'll be back
next friday for one more friday episode
of inside marvel but then after that
we're moving to wednesday
it's wednesday night loki after shows
it's gonna be fun
so follow mt at mastertainment follow me
at eavos follow new rockstars and
subscribe to inside marvel wherever you
get your podcast subscribe to new
rockstars here on youtube
thanks for watching bye
[Music]
you